what's the name of that drug again chris
isn't that sagan tucker is a man talk
talk he's talking to get this right man
is it toxin map near enough
i'm afraid that in the there is a such a
a rich thesaurus now of things that i
have said that have been uh one way or
another through what alchemy i do not
know somehow misconstrued uh that it
would really take me too long uh to
engage in a full global itinerary of
apology to to all concerned yesterday i
went uh as as we all must
uh uh
to to peppa pig world i don't know if
you've been to peppa pig world who's
been dependent he's been to
this is not all about uh some expensive
uh politically correct uh green act of
uh of
of bunny hugging uh or or however you
want to put it they're not going to be
bunny hugging but you you know what i'm
driving at
[Applause]
i just think it's it's it's time for
some of our dearest friends around the
world to you know prone and grip
about all this uh and don in one hand
break
[Music]
you